the Parliament voted to upgrade the  Civil Protection mechanism to respond  faster and better to natural disasters  since 2001 it has provided support on  300 cases inside and outside the EU  Parliament is improving motor insurance  rules to better protect road accident  victims  the new rules ensure that people across  the EU get at least six million euros in  insurance coverage per accident for  personal injuries the number of  cross-border payments grew by 56 percent  between 2014 and 2016 parliament voted  to lower payment charges for countries  outside the eurozone the next multi  annual budget should boost innovation  energy transition and access to health  care across the EU Parliament wants less  developed regions to keep benefiting  from substantial EU support of up to 85%  of co-financing from 2009 to 2015 the  number of animals transported within the  EU for breeding or slaughtering  increased by 19% members called to  improve their transport conditions and  Welfare